I hear no objections it's so decided
[Applause]
U.N climate Summit in Egypt finally an
agreement by some measures an historic
one including for the first time a
proposed loss and damage fund to
compensate developing nations for the
damage caused by climate change
for those already suffering a
breakthrough I'm happy that it it it
worked out I'm happy it got gabbled that
didn't get blocked in the night or
we built guard rails we were you know we
were tents for two nights we haven't
slept so yeah it may not be the best
it's it's the beginning it's a
tremendous outcome we've been fighting
for this for three decades and the group
has been putting forward many proposals
and the world has come together
it's amid the celebration concern and
tension the details of who pays and when
on loss and damage are still to be
agreed European nations say that major
developing economies and big polluters
like China and India must contribute
above all there are worries that cop 27
has fallen short on raising ambition
above last year's meeting in Glasgow
missing a chance to call for the phasing
down of all fossil fuels rather than
just coal and failing to push for more
emission reductions
a painful compromise for exhausted
delegates
I've been very clear in my comments that
I'm disappointed we couldn't go further
than Glasgow here and that's something
that's being echoed by other parties
particularly climate vulnerable
countries the only way you can get us
where we need to be is by quickly
reducing emissions and that's the only
way you can stay on on the 1.5 Celsius
trajectory and I have not seen progress
on that
are the UN climate Chief's own admission
this year amid a war and an energy
crisis has been hard very different from
Glasgow last year there were a lot of
concerns about backsliding
and what we have actually seen is
increased investment increased
commitment in terms of Renewables yes
there's been backsliding in terms of
fossil fuel use in response to
um to to the energy crisis
I think nearly 200 Nations to agree on
anything is difficult this chaotic
Summit in the desert heat has been more
challenging than many would have liked
but there is relief that a deal however
imperfect has been done
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News